drei monate keinen sport gemacht hier zu
richtig rein
ich kann mich nie wieder bewegen
[Musik]
martin rocket möchte wissen ob
muskelkater gut oder schlecht ist
gute frage denn viele trainieren ja nach
dem motto du spricht je größer der
mussten karte desto effektiver das
training oder über husten karte
kursieren viele halt war zum beispiel
hat man immer wieder dass muskelkater
schmerzen von milchsäure verursacht
werden wie bei sportlichen belastungen
in unseren muskeln gebildet wird durch
diese theorie wurde von wissenschaftlern
weitestgehend abgelehnt ausgelöst wird
muskelkater vor allem durch sogenannte
exzentrische muss geübt beispiel bizeps
über das hochziehen der hantel ist ein
so genannte konzentrische belastung der
muskel zieht sich zusammen die
kontrollierte rückwärtsbewegung ist eine
exzentrische belastung der muskel wird
gewählt und diese kombi ausdehnung und
belastungs besonders hart für den muskel
anderes beispiel für exzentrische
belastung bergab laufen wenn es euch
also mal richtig hart gegen wollte könnt
ihr einmal mit hanteln berg runter
laufen dabei ganz langsam die hantel
runterlassen unseren muskelfasern werden
dass struktur protein aktin und das
motorprotein myosin gegeneinander
verschoben diese proteine hängen in
einem gerüst den sogenannten z scheiben
und diese z scheiben fangen und fehlen
die bewegung so ein bisschen ab bei
muskelkater werden diese zeit schreiben
aber beschädigt schwellungen und
entzündungen sind unter anderem die
folge und die schäden müssen auch wieder
repariert werden das dauert dann seine
ein bis zwei tage so lange wir unser
muskelkater eben zu spüren bekommen das
ist aber kein problem musste kati
hinterlässt keine bleibenden schäden
aber hilft er denn beim muskelaufbau
geraden exzentrische übungen sollen
tatsächlich zu schnell im aufbau von
kraft und muskelmasse führen aber
forscher glauben dass das unabhängig vom
muskelkater passiert bei regen
mäßigen training mit langsamer stetiger
belastungssteuerung kann man auch ohne
muskelkater kraft und muskeln aufbauen
muskelkater dass er ein signal dafür
dass gewisse muskeln gewisse bewegungen
nicht gewohnt sind
das heißt für gibt es bisher keine
wissenschaftlichen belege
trotzdem darf man sich natürlich gut
fühlen wenn man muskelkater hat wenn es
ein motiviert schön schlau
vielen dank für deine frage wenn jeder
fragen habt schreibt sie in die
kommentare und